hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to five nights at
Freddy's 2 we are on to the fourth night
after mastering everything about this
game but we have another phone call to
hear which I'm kind of curious because
the last time in the first game the guy
on the phone answered the call okay
that's comforting well what am I
supposed to do about that how do I avoid
avoid eye contact oh boy alright okay
things are about to get a little weird
because saw spider Freddie foxy spider
foxy whatever the mangle I don't care
well that's spider foxy in my opinion
spider foxy and the baby are being a
little bit precarious here quite a foxy
was in the other room with the other guy
okay so I know how to do this they're
very aggressive tonight aren't they huh
oh hi hey I'll try to avoid eye contact
I guess
[Music]
okay so this is this generally just a
smooth flow in between everything else I
just need to make sure there's something
in the vents
nope not yet okay all but there's some
what about going in the vents that's
what that noise means at least it's
giving me a bit of a warning before it
happens yeah I don't know which one it
is but someone's someone's about to be
in the vents oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy
you're getting panicky getting panicky
you gotta be expeditious and quick and
accurate who's there who's in the buzzer
who is it who's it who's who's it ah
[ __ ] you over there who's in words Oh
what do I do about that I don't know Joe
I don't know what to do oh god oh god oh
god I don't know what to do about that
oh oh
[Music]
oh okay everyone's everyone's suspended
come on
okay this bath is bad this
[Applause]
I was quick enough good golly gosh what
is what did what did he do
I don't know he was just hanging up
there like a douche hey hoser Gardner
you wanna win too bad that was that was
that was it clang oh god is that spider
foxy you know hi my friend my friend
who's in the vents
someone's someone's nearby in the vents
okay got some time but the menacing
music is always up now this is always
there oh boy okay I think my problem was
that I didn't notice the mangle dude was
in the vent right next to me and he's
got in the room and that's what kind of
screwed me over
nothing could nothing would matter then
are you there no okay you're fine fine
[Music]
whoa
like I can't be quicker I literally
can't
[Applause]
oh my ears
get ready oh I'm ready I'm foxy now I'm
gonna go have a fun I'm going I'm going
what is this these minigames are like to
program oh hi minigames like the
programming for the eye and then the
bugs come in and makes everything
horrible oh I'm ready
trust me already hello
okay going
[Applause]
with the thing you do all right
Oh somehow I have to be even quicker
I like panic for a split second and I
don't know what to do
I gotta immediately throw on the mask
girls I'm done okay she's coming in the
van balloon boys coming in the van on
the left side I need to watch out for hi
hi are you here yeah you're there I just
gotta wait prefer the chit chit there we
go there we go there we go got it got it
got it I just kind of wait for the the
the sound of the vents the sounds are
very important there's a ton of audio
clues in this game I mean now that
whining sound just means that I'm about
to die because something's coming after
me but you know at least I still have
some time so just gotta listen to the
vents who do you think you are huh huh
you wanna mess with the likes of me I
got a cracking voice I'm practically
pubescent someone's in the van might be
Bonnie might be chica I'm gonna guess
this chicas because she's been a real
pain in the butt
that's bad that's what that's about okay
okay well we don't panic now don't press
the wrong buttons now okay so I just got
to be very so that guy is pretty obvious
everyone has like their audio clues when
they're coming in the vents but except
for Bonnie and chica they just get in
the vents and then they're in the room
and that's bad there's no predicting
when they're gonna be there looking
someone's in the vents
don't know who not I better see the
Bonnie or chica now oh boy who's that
who's that who's that
yeah okay Bonnie's here Bonnie's here by
about there okay she's gotta be very
very very quick on the draw here okay I
feel he's moving around someone's
already in the benzo
that was quick those good don't you dare
lose your [ __ ] there okay okay okay
okay okay
okay we're fine we're fine we're fine
fine we're [ __ ] fine we're forget
fine forget fine but Bonnie's on the way
so I gotta be quick
oh man I mean hello are you there okay
you're not there yet but you might be in
the vents
that's good because that's Bonnie's vent
if he's taking over Bonnie's vent then
I'm actually okay somebody else's in the
vent though it might be what's this
[ __ ] like just ah damn [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] did I do okay I didn't do that okay
I'm fine I'm fine I'm fine I'm fine fine
that's literally all you need to do wait
until you hear the vents but I bet like
ona really hard difficulty I'm not even
gonna be able to tell what vent is going
where it's gonna be a blur of vents
sounds and then I'm gonna be dead a
million types of dead who's coming after
me next I don't have time to look so
make it a good surprise and hopefully
all good as chica maybe I do need to
look and that's the thing maybe that
gives me like extra time I don't know it
just it detracts from my cycle honor
Oh God that sounded bad Oh God that
sounded bad that sounded bad you're
trying me from lining up the baby
whining and keeping the baby instead
hello are you there
no yeah why can't I do that why can't I
look in front of me god damn it
oh hi okay avoid eye contact no no no no
no no now stop that god damn you what's
the thing move along move along baby
move along move along hi are you there
you weren't there before okay you're not
there now that's all that matters okay I
gotta get this thing back up
Oh to the [ __ ] both of the cent [ __ ]
Fantasia the [ __ ] okay come on oh
[ __ ] I can't look down the hallway come
on come on come on give me give me give
me go okay there we go how'd you get
back there already I know the music box
requires my attention can't you see that
I'm in a little bit of a panic Oh God
Oh what do you you were just Bonnie
don't try to fool me
I'll fools right back with you nothing
no box I know I know I know
I'm well aware of what the music box is
doing right now I'm well aware of
everything right now
God time is going six live
dawn and yet panicked again [ __ ] [ __ ]
god this is him oh [ __ ] me spider-man
Spidey Fox spider Fox spider Fox does
whatever a spider Fox says can t swing
from Moab no he can't
he'll just murder you look out he's
right behind you okay oh god I know I
know I know I know things are bad thank
you bad things are bad but things are
okay
were you there okay black go away okay I
know I know I know I know I know I know
I know I know I know I know I know I
know I know give me a like give me a
like give me a goddamn like I know I
know I know you're very funny
everything's hilarious to you I wanna
win someone's in the vents who's in the
vents
hi Greg vodkas comfortable oh boy
I was doing from balloon boy first
I wish those differentiating music to
know like who exactly is where and why
and how and why and how and where oh hi
Freddie
what are you doing there oh god oh god
oh god I don't know what to do with that
I don't know how to respond Freddie
Freddie says must be here all someone's
in the band it's not happy so I must be
chica or Bonnie Bonnie messages Oh
criminey Christmas I can't do it she
could be coming up she could be coming
up you're not there I know you're not I
just looked down the hallway someone's
on the hallway someone's down the
hallway Oh Freddie's down the hallway
don't know what Freddy B's
I think blowing by pop-top - okay yeah I
know I know Freddie's there he's giving
me the stink-eye
don't know what to do about that for now
just let me what the [ __ ] I gotta get
the music box oh no no no no no no no no
not the music oh [ __ ] you
[Applause]
[ __ ] let me okay okay okay okay okay
okay okay okay okay okay gotta get this
music box up all right this is gonna be
ready for anything
anything can pop up on me at any moment
gotta be ready
well hi Freddie you're here early I know
you're gonna pop up on me I know I know
but I'm ready
that's all boy already ready for Freddie
ready for all of you all of you sons of
[ __ ] okay I think the mangle is
coming the mangles coming but anybody
else could be coming at the same time
need to be ready need to be ready he's
here
who's there a little boy is in there
does someone else be in there too huh is
it a double-wide vent huh figure tussle
with me god damn it if that was late
[ __ ] light I should just put on my
head just put on my head and say good
night
son I should do say goodbye
I'm fine I'm fine I'm fine all the time
of the world all the time in the world
hold the diamond off mother time in the
world yes damn it yes
oh yes don't know okay all right hey you
son of a [ __ ] you puppet master [ __ ]
[Music]
thank you thank you fish that last night
last night but I got the tire you down
oh it's amazing how this game
transitions between panic and more panic
he goes such a smooth trajectory from
absolute utter terror which there still
is some of to absolute utter panic like
everything is wrong all the time but
it's still really really awesome this is
this is a big improvement from the first
one not that the first one was bad but I
really love how they expanded in
different directions in this one it is
just a nightmare I don't know why it
needs to be this hard but there you go
so I'm gonna finish it up soon thank you
all so much for watching click the
annotation for more videos that I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video
[Music]
Oh